[Music]
you must be feeling real good coming off
of that feeling good still a little
sweaty but we're feeling good I still
have the counts and steps in my head of
that dance we learned it last night as
the last minute I know I learned it last
night well today yeah yeah so as we're
talking it's 2 3 do it I think that the
Backstreet Boys needs to add you like as
part of officially part of the group I
know that you're touring all that 7 7
man band did you guys see the Tim McGraw
was going crazy when you guys started
dancing somebody just showed us a clip
and we actually were just hanging with
and that's what took us a minute to get
over here but uh delayed we saw the
video he's pouring he goes I was
pointing at you because you were nailing
all the moves you got him I was like I
appreciate that to laugh at that Tim
knows the Backstreet Boy moves that's
crazy I bet he does everybody in the
audience they were going nuts they were
not starting performance I mean faith
and nicole kidman did you see all them
in the audience
no what I didn't really see them at the
very at the moment that we were dancing
but I saw everybody having a good time
and that's that was a moment we've been
waiting for all day
and it's kind of nice that it's over but
at the same time that was a blast that
was so much fun the Backstreet Boys are
amazing and they're great teachers as
well seriously and obviously still
extremely popular
you know they got I mean timeless hits
and they're there they're staying
creative they're staying busy they're
staying fresh and they got great
attitudes positive energy and they're
like brothers we've really created a
cool bond and in almost mentorship at
times too you know it's it's really
special you know we've shared some
success thus far but I think the
friendship more than anything means a
lot to us it really does that's why the
dance moves so well dancing that gets
you know we had our first dance lesson
today
Nick Horner yeah that's not a bad
instructor no mad about that the women
love it when you can dance really well
you know
[Music]